so today we're starting Aristotle's
metaphysics we're going to spend two
days we could spend in a total master
which is what some people do when
they're in graduate school we go over
line by line and look at it very
carefully we're only looking at the
first book so you might think of this is
we're peering our head around the corner
of the door listening to Aristotle and
his students as they talk about some
really fundamental but difficult to
understand stuff and I don't expect that
anybody's going to immediately get this
like that I didn't myself immediately
understand all of this the first the
second the third you know time then I
read it and I'm still finding more and
more stuff in this as I go through it
myself which is why it's a classic work
every time you approach a class of work
you'll find a little bit more to
contribute a little bit more that you
hadn't thought of before so Aristotle
starts off with this famous quote
usually translated all men desire to
know this is this is a classroom which
is about three-quarters women I mean the
you don't desire to know just men do
Aristotle actually had some kind of
sexist views he thought women were
naturally inferior to bad you know all
sorts of stuff like that but that was
you know part of his culture in part
because of some strange commitments on
his friend he didn't have to be stuck
with the word that we translate as men
in older translations actually means
human beings doesn't mean Mabel it means
human beings so all human beings desire
to know what do they want to know and
why did he do we all desire to know
metaphysics how many of you signed up
for this interim philosophy class
nobody nobody said you know well I know
it's a required course let's say it
wasn't a required course how many of you
have taken this course gone - yeah you
know we want to know other things how
many of you want to know you all do it
right otherwise you would be in college
because what is college about is getting
to to know things so what I'd like you
to do just for a couple minutes I'd like
you to get out a piece of paper and I'm
going to ask you a couple questions that
I want you to write down some responses
these are all pretty simple I don't
think that they're going to acquire an
awful lot of self scrutiny or anything
like that
the first one is what are you what do
you want to study all of your freshmen
so you haven't said a major yet but I'm
guessing that all of you have some
general idea something we might want to
study some of you are probably here
precisely to study this thing or that
thing because Marist has a lot of pretty
good programs so all of you have some
sort of idea what's the one thing that
you right now at this moment are
planning on majoring here major in here
at Marist College so that's the first
thing
they're putting up that dump okay
now I want you to imagine for the moment
that you won the lottery or you know
somebody died and left you a huge estate
or something like that you are never
going to have to work again in your life
let's say you're actually going to stay
here at Marist College
I can imagine you all like it here right
bad foods with it I can tell you that in
your cafeteria compared to other places
I've done
so you're independently wealthy but
you're going to stay in the school what
would you study or maybe you wouldn't
stay in school maybe you go somewhere
else
but let's say you are going to study
something what would you study what
field
this will take a little bit more fun
this is a question you said so like
would we change or studying if we got
all that money twice or you might not
actually you're saying what should what
we would want to study if we had if you
didn't have any worries about money or
time or any less your actually started
getting ahead to the question I was
going to ask my sort of show of hands
how many of you if money was no concern
whatsoever would study exactly the same
thing in your study one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen and fourteen fifteen
sixteen sixteen out of about twenty four
people here so that is about what 60
percent that's unusual actually a lot of
places that I've talked before most of
the people that were there were going
into fields and why were they going into
the fields because they figure those are
where the jobs are or they're profitable
and they're not particularly interested
in this particular thing but you know
it's a means to an end
earning a goodly earning a good living
usually not the case with art students
music students because it's hard to make
money with those and you know very
demanding but a lot of students yeah
that's what they do okay so I have one
other question for you I want you to
write down what you think your two most
indispensable for your life for how you
live your two most indispensable piece
is that pretty pretty easy one for you
to think of or not it's hard when you
have to narrow things down that's why I
don't say like the five top ones that's
easy to answer and you don't say that
just one because then alright so the
third question I'm going to ask you
about later first question let's let's
start with what are you guys actually
studying what you're doing criminal
justice I write communication okay we
talked about that after class
communication what do you say business
psychology yeah fireman was it biomed
biomed how was that different than sound
like a combination of biology and
medicine so you're like on the med
medical track graphic design do you do
that
through an art department yura do you do
that through the fashion department all
right okay I know they've got this
families with interesting signs up there
property of fashion ology I didn't even
know there was such a thing as fashion
ology but apparently there is
I know fashion but didn't know was an
ology yeah
what are you already gonna study okay no
no idea no yearning or anything did you
have did you have anything that if money
was no object you would actually say oh
that's interesting that's what my sister
does
yeah and you don't make a lot of money
that's one of the things I think holding
people back but there are some things
that are very rewarding well what other
yeah education yeah okay all right
anybody else have any other ones that
aren't up there yeah chemistry yeah
imagine merchandising in fashion ology
is stored it's like a student-run store
okay so it's not like a class or
anything I thought maybe it was a very
you know in food studies they have and I
didn't know about this until I I got
involved with culinary people they have
this whole field called astronomy and
it's like the study of the history of
food and all that well why doesn't it
just history of food well let's get
strata so I thought maybe fashion ology
sort of something like that types of
fashion so fashion Lexington okay I'm
just going to put down fashion what else
what else are going to study what other
fields are people going into did anyone
else have anything that's not up here
for your majors know who he had anything
for what they would do if there wasn't
any you know when he was an object who
had anything else besides these big
study yeah hi this is awful I'd probably
go to beauty school and do little makeup
in here but I just don't want I didn't
want to stay like where I was
to move so I wanted to like it I wanted
natural leaders that's right my mom you
know my mom used to be a secretary at
this place called the school of
aesthetics and cosmetology when I was in
high school and so I go there and I need
free haircuts and all that sort of stuff
and she's she was always trying to get
the girls that should pay him a little
extra cough as much hair as possible
because yeah I should know how to spell
it
you know another reason I should know
why it is or how to spell it it comes
from a Greek word that actually does
means beauty and also the cosmos did
anyone else have any other things in
person it would be a musician or yeah
man okay that's something you would
pursue if money wasn't Ananya okay what
else nobody gives like things like our
music or oh it's such elementary - okay
education yes what are you majoring or
planning bio major I wanna be a
pediatrician okay did anyone have
anything like adding any other sciences
that they would like to study but
they're not planning us that anymore
any of humanities anyone want to be a
story or a poet write literature
make music any of these sorts of things
anyone want to go to culinary school
we're going to cook really well actually
a lot more than that but learn how to
run a restaurant or how to break things
down okay well this is a good list to
thou'rt Aristotle talks about arts and
skills disciplines we call and how they
developed over time how did they in fact
develop he gives you sort of a story and
this tells us a little bit about what
metaphysics is going to be because we're
concerned with what wisdom is wisdom and
metaphysics are connected metaphysics
comes very very late in the game and one
of the things that you know if you're
taking a risk to an approach you would
do with things we're going to talk a lot
more about this next time is really ask
the why question why are things the way
they are why are things what they are
why do we pursue them and for each one
of these these arts or sciences or
skills or techniques or whatever you
want to call them we can ask what is the
point of it what you know and this may
be different for you than what the point
of the actual skill is somebody might
want to become a doctor in part because
they want to heal people that's what the
goal of Medicine is right or they might
want to become a doctor because they you
know saw what's a medical show sort of
blanking on thinking CSI but that's more
forensic what's another general hospital
or scrubs
obviously scrubs
they're pretty miserable do you like
yeah I do too but I wouldn't want to
live their life so
you can an strategies what is what is
their point why do human beings do this
with them and you might say just to make
money or you know for some internal
gratification rush it
for instance you might become a chemist
or might become a chemistry major
because you really enjoy playing with
test tubes you know I knew it I knew a
kid in high school who used to steal all
the chemistry equipment and he was very
what's that it was here he was really
enterprising and once saw him to take a
leader being here now by sucking in his
stomach and then you know putting it
under his sweatshirt and you know by the
end of the semester half the stuff was
gone now what he was doing with it I
don't know he just seemed to like yeah I
don't think he was cooking mouth because
this is back before that let's begin
popular the 90s is back if he was doing
chemistry he wasn't doing it for the
reason that chemists actually do right
what what a chemists actually you know
why are we interested in chemistry well
it produces all sorts of great things
for us like pretty much everything in
this room including our bodies they've
all been modified by by a lot of
chemicals at one point or another
business you can say why why do people
go into business I want to make tons of
money but if that's really your case you
shouldn't go business school you should
probably just start a business all right
you have a better chance of making lots
of money unless you know you're going to
be a big executive or something like
that maybe it grooms your for that but
really what is the point of a business
it's not just making money why they give
you that money
you have to give other people things in
return I have to give there's a catch
phrase
Goods and goods and services and if
you're not doing that you won't stay in
business or if your goods and services
aren't very good compared to competitors
you won't stay in business business
school is about learning how to how to
manage that sort of stuff well or how to
market it or how to finance
communications why do people study
communications you can go into a lot of
you know communication psychology those
are two degrees that are very very
portable most of the people who get a
psychology degree don't work in
psychology they work in some other field
why is it what what does psychology also
another way communications provide even
the person who studies it understanding
of what well um maybe critical thinking
reasoning certainly but something even
more basic what makes people tick yeah
oh yeah how people think
exactly so you might actually be a good
person for business if you've got a
psych degree you really study the topic
we could have therapeutic purposes you
might be trying to heal somebody Social
Work is related to psychology in part
because you know what Social Work
actually is is getting people resources
and helping them unscrew up their life
when you have a social worker involved
it's usually because somebody's really
screwed things up or a whole bunch of
people screw things up and you know it
helps to know how they did it why they
did fix it what's the point of Education
to teach other people yeah to teach
other people what whatever your topic is
all this other stuff right education is
kind of a funny field in that way you
can actually get a doctorate degree in
education but in order to really be an
educator you have to know some subject
really well besides education otherwise
you've got nothing with teach anybody
but you know there are good ways to
teach people and bad ways to teach
people I knew when I was at Fayetteville
State University one of the old school
professors his pedagogical method was to
yell at his students and to slam things
around and he gave them a lot of work
and then he would just yell at them I
actually called security the first time
that I was down the hall from him
because one of the students was raising
his voice too and I thought that there
was like a fight breaking out that's not
good pedagogy right that's not good
teaching wouldn't you know you all have
good teachers in the past I said right
what did they do that helped you learn
what do you remember they're probably
nice but that's not what makes you a
good teacher
okay patience so they did the same thing
over and over again with you right walk
you through it
anything else did they seem prepared for
the class when they got there or they
just kind of make it up as they went a
little fact I've noticed the people who
do that who literally don't know what
they're going to say what they they get
to the room
fashion what's the point of fashion
there's a point to what's up yeah we all
do wear clothes we don't have to wear
fashion whose do it you could all wear
the same thing that I'm wearing we do
that this could be our uniform rod
purrew this is maroon right this color
maroon shirt brown pants could all have
vests like this maybe you guys know what
to wear ties and then we take it easy on
you and take you get your BA or a BS
right or BBS and also the GPS degrees so
it's not just about clothes well that's
that's more the business end of it yeah
it like makes people feel better about
themselves
yeah that's that's key people buy
clothes because they think the clothes
look good yeah and you know a lot of
that subjective and you know what looks
good for you might not look good for me
back like I remember my mom you said
lots of clothes and there was this book
that came out that was really
influential in the 1980s for fashion
divided people in the four seasons you
might be a spring or summer or fall and
you have to figure out which one you are
because if you're in the summer Africa
this work you have to wear these colors
if your fall or these colors well what
was going on there that sounds kind of
complicated doesn't yeah I didn't
understand it myself either
and she tried to explain it but what was
the point behind it what was the end the
purpose it was to have people look good
and why did why do people want to look
good because then they like you said
they feel good right we enjoy things we
get pleasure out of things that look
good that's aesthetics
you know cosmetology makeup why do
people wear makeup just because it's
part of the uniform and you have to wear
it no because people want things to look
nice why do we you know care about you
know look at this classroom this is not
a particularly aesthetically pleasing
classroom but it's not bad either you
know a door the doors at least are
painted the walls are painted you know
I've taught in places where that's not
the case and those things affect people
you know are the values of the values of
our lives but how how our life has lived
out whether it's felt to be a good life
or not depends in part on those things
there's some legitimate value to it
you know musicians produce things that
we like to hear
quicks produced thing with you're like
you could just eat oatmeal all the time
and take pills and you'd probably be
okay right
if you didn't take the pills you get
scurvy but there was actually a girl
when I was in graduate school down in
southern was away she got scurvy
she tried living on potatoes to save
money you know so all she was potatoes
for like two months she got skirt
when it's a fifty a vitamin C deficiency
which which is very hard for us to have
in this society because everything's
might even see loaded into it right but
you know all you eat is potatoes
there's no buoyancy in potatoes they
well they've you know that scene because
they will didn't have any vitamin C so
all of these things all these arms they
all developed at one point in time to
meet some need to satisfy something
education you know 150 years ago you
couldn't specialize in education
business you know we never we only have
MBAs and we can actually get a PhD in
business until recently in Europe you
couldn't get an MBA because they felt
that that's not something you can
actually teach you have to learn that on
the job each one of these things
developed as a discipline in time and
they didn't all developed at once the
world that we live in is the product of
a lot of different things happening over
and over and over again progress being
made
that's what Aristotle is talking about
the first part of the Memphis he talks
about a couple different motives for why
people develop arts or skills and one of
these you have to do this is what he
called the necessary or useful right
medicine is is useful keeps you alive
most likely you know for any given human
population nowadays if you didn't have
modern medicine half you would be dead
right now I know I certainly would we
didn't have all the things that modern
medicine provides us you'd have died in
some of you know epidemic or when you
broke your arm septic or something like
that why the diet scurvy and recommend
all right yeah people working people
were dying of scurvy just two hundred
years ago what else what else are like
absolutely necessary arts or skills
making pottery that's one of the first
skills that develops agriculture
nobodies you know farming then where are
we going to get our food what's the
other alternative I can gather and if
you want to go out of the woods and look
for berries hunt squirrels sounds got a
romantic you know your Alden and you
know through row and stuff like that but
what do you actually have to do it's not
fun especially when you don't know what
you're doing you know there's actually a
great a great book and movie very
controversial come into the wild have
any variant seen that yeah yeah I saw
that recently I'm thinking about writing
something about it because my reaction
was Kathy cuz you're responsible you
know and my you know a lot of other
people were like oh yeah he's this hero
what about our other necessary eyes that
we end up pursuing well you know so we
have food agriculture we have
storing things medicine what else do we
need architecture yeah our you know
these building houses in this not
architecture necessarily in building the
Washington grindin construction house
building you know making clothing
somebody had to actually feel how to
weave this stuff yeah see the data
you're going to wear bark how very
animal scared some people do this you
know not not like oak bark or stuff like
that but some people do our part and
once we get past the necessary in the
useful people and these things start to
make our life
better this is a sort of history of
human progress then we get to arts that
give fire now it's no longer just a
matter of having clothing now it's a
matter of having good looking for now
there's no longer manages to have food
feed and you know learning how to cook
it now if you put the meat on the fire
it's easier to digest that's that sort
of necessary stuff now I'm just start
thinking about how do I make this
actually tastes good
how do I please people how do i do
things that are pleasant and those
produce a lot of other good things all
right and that makes our lives better
yet
and this is again story of human
progress and those who can do this are
more highly regarded Aristotle says than
those who just supply the necessities
we're doing things that are merely
useful they're seen as being closer to
wisdom eventually what all this offers
us get through this we have these we
were able to take it easy you don't have
to work as hard
we have surpluses we resources maybe not
everybody in the society as a matter of
fact in ancient societies they were all
slave societies just about every single
society that developed pest hunting
gathering and slaves on them in one way
or another they may not have called them
slaves but mostly Mantha and that was
the way it was forever for quite a long
time and even when we had industrial
society did everybody you know share
equally and the benefits of it no and
they still don't even completely today
these things are pretty good
historically speaking compared to when
you would have died screwed right but
you know like we can multiply
I want to get through this we have
leisure what is leisure offered here the
possibility could just take it easy
right enjoy yourself
is that the kind of action or response
that continues given progress some
people will do that maybe even most
people will do that societies in which
some people say now I'm actually free to
leave societies where some people start
to say you know I don't have to work for
a living
I'd really like to study this I've
always wanted to learn about this there
are some things that are intrinsic there
are some things that people study not
because they're going to get something
out of it but because they want to know
about that because the the object itself
draws them in so if you actually do
enjoy mathematics and you start making
progress of that when I can understand
that because when I was a an
undergraduate I was both a philosophy
major and a math major and I ended up
going to graduate school for philosophy
but I understand the allure is you know
elegant beautiful complex problems
concepts all these sort of things and
once you put in enough time they start
to sort of unpack themselves for you
just like you know any of you that are
interview play music those of you that
are musicians you know that more time
that you put in with it doing boring
things like scales and and all that
suddenly things open up for you and you
see things
rather pure things and you feel things
that you didn't before and you come to
understand them those are things that
are intrinsically worthwhile given the
chance to pursue them people do what
often keeps them from being able to do
that is being occupied with with this
stuff now Aristotle talks about
metaphysics in this life metaphysics is
the one that's sort of at the top of the
scale
so let's you know for the rest of the
period let's try and run what is this
metaphysics stop or discipline I mean
the in our society like I put it out in
another lecture
you know some people think metaphysics
is crystals or past lives or that is
that is a certain type of by the physics
but that's natural soft metaphysics it's
just boring the occult or things like
that
actually though before I before I go
into this I did he ask you that second
question third question so what are the
most important pieces of technologies
here what can you not do without that's
interesting eighths of the internet
because that is technology that's it's
not yours you know internet but you
certainly make use of it yeah I think
about all the things that had to take
place before the internet then hear your
phone yeah these things are awfully
handy right thing when I I am here too
it's a Maris one day I forgot my is a
day that I was here for the whole day
forgot my phone at home this has all my
good email stuff buttons
it's how I access half of my social
networks of course I use it to call
people as well take pictures store data
I know when you leave something like
this behind you feel kind of naked
culture it's almost like leaving for men
this behind and have you ever misplace
your wallet that is scary
isn't that this is also a piece of
technology though I think the reason why
I asked you this question about
technologies I imagine most of you
probably some things like this right
how many of you actually said your phone
is your most work piece of everything
else every single one of it yeah but
this is technology to anything that
human beings have made through art or
craft or skill Greek techn a that's what
we get technology from is technology
this is technology this is very
complicated technology ties in with an
entire network of things even this
business card is technology you have you
have technology surrounding yourself
it's not just electronic devices you're
wearing technology all of this stuff was
produced through these massive supply
chains you know this doesn't grow on
trees right where you don't find this in
the wild you have to this is this I
think a cotton shirt so somebody
actually had to pick the cotton and you
know get all the seeds out and then turn
it into cloth and then the cloth had to
go to the factory where it was actually
sewn I'm going to come you know through
the supply chain over here where I could
buy at the store and now I'm wearing
this is all technology you are
constantly surrounded by technology that
came from all of these artists now with
all of these arts they all have a
certain we're Sciences they all have a
certain circumstance um things up right
you ignore certain things if you're
looking at things from a chemical
perspective you leave some things up if
you're a psychologist looking at
people's emotions you may look at them
in a very different way than a
neurologist watching brain states does
if you're an artist you look at paints
in a very different way than a chemist
does right in all these cases these Arts
and Sciences are telling you questions
about what and why what things are why
they are the way they are why they are
that thing metaphysics is the science or
the art however you want to put in that
studies all of it and here's where we
make sort of shift metaphysics is about
okay what is VN everything around
yourself included your thoughts
everything you will ever encounter in
your existence everything you're not
encounter in your existence is being
being of one former it up here's a human
being here's another one there's another
one yeah
inanimate beings alright we have other
inanimate beings we have beings that you
can't see like the thoughts in your head
they have existence right your memories
okay you might you know get very
technical and say well my memories exist
in my brain my brain is a bunch of
neurons okay that's a car being your
experience of it isn't them that's not
something corporeal necessarily but it
has being the words that I'm speaking at
being metaphysics is not confined to
studying just one kind of we're studying
being in one particular way it's looking
at being is another best position later
on being as such
that's a hard concept to wrap your head
around what are all these things that
you experience some of them you don't
even experience you just think of like
numbers what all of them you have in
common
that's what metaphysics studies and one
of the things that metaphysics does is
it looks at what we call causes this is
the concept you're familiar with right
let's let's take a real simple instance
so I've got this we call these cup
jackets
collars there's a word for it
I'll sleep good okay which is yeah it
live the [ __ ] up sleeve fell why because
I dropped it is that the whole story
gravity pulled it down and effect tape
took place we can look at that and we
can say what are the clauses of these
sorts of things let's think about
another thing I'm going to pass this
around
I laid around this is one of my favorite
books and I don't just mean favorite in
the sense that I really like this this
particular book in in general and I
could buy the copy of it and you know
like you know I like Shakespeare's
Hamlet and it doesn't matter whether you
give me one that's got gold leaf or you
know an iPhone or something like that I
like Shakespeare's Hamlet
this is actually a book that has this
particular object I really like this is
one of the ones I've read when I
actually have to do so and one of the
reasons I like it is I can I can get
something out of it that a lot of people
can't and I save this from destruction
when they were throwing about the
library was actually getting rid of this
in part does know very few people can
read this anymore
it's a Grimm's fairy tales and it's it's
in German and I'm going to pass it
around you can see it's in the old
German script that it will read it
because the Nazis kind of screwed right
off right Nazis used this script so
after that they didn't teach German kids
how to how to read it anymore it's
called the tractor now how did this come
to be
you can Hance that in a lot of different
ways think about this physical object
you can ask a lot of questions about
this when you ask first of all what do
we know it's what can you tell me it's a
book it's a book right so it has a
certain shape or structure or form write
a book is different than say an iPhone
can you open up an iPhone rise you know
you take the cover off a book you can
actually open and go through it as a
particular structure shape to it right
remember what I said books were before
they were this sort of thing this is
what we call labellum but were they
rolls right that had a different form a
different shape but you notice it had
the same function didn't that what does
this make up hey yeah for the most part
I think the no I mean I guess the
outside cover part is a different kind
of paper I think oh there's some other
things game Clue you know whatever else
is in I'm gonna book maker that's a
different question though what is it
made of
then what is its shape or form what else
can you ask about it how did this come
to be
this particular physical object what
sort of processes have to take place
yeah now that that applies to all of
Grimm's fairy tales what about this
particular object this physical object
you know it's made out of some stop it
and you just take a bunch of paper put
it out there and say there's your book
yeah there's a publisher and the
publisher does a bunch of stuff to it
right like the originally the pages are
not like this they're these long things
and they stamp it with a printing press
nowadays these laser printers clean
process but Rios efficient yeah but it's
the same idea that you take the paper
you change it in some way
and then you put it all together I think
this book is actually not just glued
glued but so you can actually see that
when you look at this older books this
is why older books tend to last a long
time they're they're actually sewn into
the cover so somebody actually had to
make this object and then you can also
ask what's the point of this why does
this object exist you can say it exists
in parkas has made the paper and all
that it exists because it's a misshape
it exists because somebody actually took
the time to fabricate it why did they do
that what's the point of the book is
that some people think the point of a
book is to sit on the shelf right there
there's active every generation there's
a lot of people who buy lots of books
and they put them on the shelf and I
think this is going to make me smart
because you know now I own the knowledge
in this book you really own the
knowledge in the book you read it [ __ ]
thought that until you read it well the
purpose of the book is it is reading is
to there might be other purposes to get
pleasure like grandma actually with a
grimm brothers do you know what one of
the reasons for writing this book was
anybody a student of Germanic languages
or
these are all fairy tales and household
tales house marriage and these are
stories that have been told orally by
lots of people for generations and
because of the industrial society the
Grimm's realized hey the people who are
telling the stories they're going to die
out and they're not going to pass these
stories on these are some really good
stories so we had better you know get
with these people and write these
stories down and that's that's exactly
what they did and a lot of the things
that you see you know coming from say
Disney are Grimm's tales with some of
the gory parts taken out you know like
Cinderella for example this make girls
feel a little good in the real story
Cinderella's sisters don't just have a
bad time they actually like you know try
to cut their their heels off so they can
fit into the glass slipper Grimm's world
is a lot bloodier it's nice like if
somebody is it's more fitting they were
really mean to her and her thing brews
world is a world of rough-and-ready
justice we might say but for any object
you can think of it for this I don't
just mean this cup I mean this this
coffee you can ask about its being you
can ask about human beings do they have
a a purpose you know what they're made
of
you know you know how they come to be
right because you'll have health class
and they taught you sex ed right even if
you didn't have that you heard it on the
playground I'm sure Bob had explained it
you know what the shape of human being
is the form of human being is recognize
it every day when you look in the mirror
to quit right
awful start is there a purpose demon
this is another question again we're not
going to answer that one this week we're
going to answer that so these these
causes Aristotle talks about them in
four ways the four causes and he's got
special terms for these and I would like
you to learn these terms and you're
going to want to practice with us to
think about this I created a handout
that will help us
fares for any given thing when you ask
what it is you're asking in part what is
its essence what is its form what is it
that makes it what it is so if I say
human being and I want you to point out
a human being all of you can do that
really quickly right all right any
person in this class what do they all
have to come what is what is there
therefore there's a couple ways we can
look at this you don't you don't have to
answer that right now
I mean want to be that the shape right
somebody comes in here and they've got
tentacles it might not be a human being
somebody comes in and they've got ET
knives or spider legs or something like
that and they could be a superhero or a
supervillain perhaps we have these
imaginary things but but in real life we
would be tempted to say the non human
being somebody comes in on all fours and
they're hairy and they have a long snout
and lots of teeth and they bark is that
a human being whatever could be probably
just a dog but it could be a werewolf
could be a human being dressed up in a
strange costume so there are certain
things the thing has we call
a formal cause he has a particular
structure why is this a book and I mean
this wouldn't work because it's quantum
why is this a plot and this is not a
book it's this is major paper this is
made of paper this has a particular
structure right it's things put together
in a certain way
think about your your human body or
thing as well let's let's not gross you
actually think about cows instead I have
you guys like hamburgers I love
hamburgers myself you are eating a piece
of comedy - hamburger right yeah that's
one reason a lot of people don't like
eat hamburgers because they think of the
pork how what's up I mean I did yeah I
have been I'm not big on the rights
person I'm not a vegetarian that lived
at one time so you take a cow how does
it become a hamburger when you cut it
into a bunch of pieces and you know some
of those we throw away or we gives you
dogs you know the bones or actually
cooks gross those to make those into
soup and then we take parts of the meat
and as the meat still the cow yet the
meat doesn't have that structure of the
cow the meats just meat same thing with
with you know a dead person there their
corpse is no longer animate its lost
something that that made all those
organs and bones and all that hold
together and that's not going to do
anything crazy you can talk about what
things are made
as their material cause that's why they
are the way they are
think about meet again hopefully none of
you have ever had a bad knee alright but
you know if meat goes bad it's not
really the same thing it's it's material
structure is as broken down as change
would a book like this made out of what
could substitute for paper some sort of
plastic right it would still have the
same formal structure let's say it has
all the letters with passion casa
surrounding you guys we take a look at
is the broad attend specifically this so
you guys can actually look at it and
think about these clauses it would have
a different material cause though
wouldn't it let's say we can actually in
a science fiction world make a human
being exactly like say mr. Cohen a
replicant of some sort will make them
out of non-human things you know making
my plastics Robert who knows what else
but he has exactly the same
characteristics as does mr. still
wouldn't be exactly the same thing with
it because it wouldn't have the same
manner you'd have a different material
cause what else we can talk about what
Aristotle calls the official cause that
which makes the thing
come to be and when some efficient
clauses are sort of unintelligent right
when I drop the sleeve did gravity think
oh crap I got to get on this oh girl let
me pull this thing down
No right gravity is not an intelligent
cause but it is an efficient cause it
makes things happen when there is some
sort of intelligence at work that we can
discern well there's some sort of
purpose then we have we call a final
cause and all four of these aerosol says
you might be right about this we might
be wrong but this is the thought I want
you to try on for a while if we tick all
four of these and we understand them
thoroughly we understand them adequately
we understand what a thing really is
much more than just saying that it's a
book if you know that the purpose is to
be read a book maker structure of a book
paper and glue and stuff like that now
you actually know a lot more about that
object let's think about this in a few
other cases and then we're going to do a
lot more than next class a sickness
disease what is it you know that a
physician actually studies when they're
trying to figure out let's say a virus
you're all familiar with
right you got enough basic biology to
know that virus is different than the
bacteria what does a virus actually do
what is a virus first of all anybody
something that makes it sick right does
it want to make you sick viruses don't
have wants actually they do the final
Clause the hantavirus action does make
you say different than bacteria viruses
go inside your cells they're really
really tiny
so manufacturers debate about whether
they're even alive or dead don't they
try to change like the VI and your each
salt cell I said that exactly they they
go inside the cell and they inject a bit
of their DNA into your DNA or a dog's
DNA or whatever you know pigs DNA and
what does that do that much about that
cell it screws up the cell but it screws
it up in a very distinctive way what is
the why does the virus actually do that
so that I got the cells your food
the cells reproduce why they don't
reproduce themselves what are they
copies of what exact they cells normally
make copies of themselves right the
virus comes in and it takes over the
code and it makes hundreds of new
viruses